we'd like to sell the breath of the wild
announced an expansion pass for $20 I'm
starting I believe you you can like pay
for it now if you preorder it but if
that so that I want to talk about
because people are like kind of outraged
about this I want to talk about why
Zelda is getting that kind of scrutiny
when we kind of come to grips with the
fact that every other franchise can do
this so just to run through quick what
it'll include we it'll be twenty dollar
expansion pass for the year there will
be an update in like right at launch on
March third when the switch and breath
the wild release one in the summer and
then one during the holiday you have
here the expansion pass that releases at
launch will be three new treasure chests
containing useful items found in the
great plateau area of the open world the
exclusive England clothing is this is
the part I have a problem with it's a
t-shirt that link can wear that just
promotes a Nintendo switch we can get
back to that because that's but that's
the only problem I have with this DLC
pack one adds new Cave of trials
challenge if you played Twilight
Princess probably sounds familiar to you
it's kind of a boss enemy run or at
least it wasn't Twyla princess I'm not
sure how it's going to manifest in
breadth of the wild there's a new hard
mode so is entire kind of mode meaning
withheld make kind of like a resonable
sevens DLC additional map feature I
don't know if that's an area or who
knows uh and then we have the holiday
new original story a new dungeon and
additional challenges so someone on
Twitter actually asked the question that
I wanted to roll with it was rayquaza
Kingdom said why is the L say why is DLC
okay with any non Nintendo game but
Zelda gets it and it's a travesty so
that's a good question because you know
Zelda's one of those franchises we kind
of hold up as being like there's a
sanctity to it that you can't touch and
until like Hyrule warriors came around
they started branching off into
different kind of formats but I don't
necessarily have a complete problem with
this Nintendo has always kind of been in
its own bubble and I think they're
opening up to other modern game trends
but it just disappoints me that this is
the first one we hear about instead of
like knowing exactly how online
capabilities are going to work with a
Nintendo switch launch but I also don't
like the fact that link can have an
Tendo switch shirt on I don't think
that's a cool I mean it's gimmicky and
it's like if you play the Wii U version
of breath a while which we all did at e3
he's got that tablet which is clearly
like the gamepad from the Wii U it's
just Nintendo's brick-like doesn't
always know how to break the fourth wall
and that worries me that they're so
behind on these DLC expansion pasts
trends that they're gonna [ __ ] it up
that it's such a small thing this shirt
that link can wear but it makes me think
that they don't exactly know what
they're doing the rest of stuff I'm fine
with because if I love breath wild which
it looks like I will I have no idea I
haven't played more two hours of it but
I've been watching streams everything I
have no problem with paying more money
for more of the game if I really like it
but this leads me to believe that they
don't necessarily have it in their grasp
what they want to do with it yeah I mean
I I think I really like your point about
like is this really the first trend like
the first modern trends are going to
approach because Nintendo is notoriously
slow on the uptake with those kinds of
things I mean I that's probably too
harsh I think Nintendo kind of just goes
its own way I don't really see a problem
with deals it doesn't bother me at all I
don't know why that's something to get
actually angry about there's other
things I'd get a lot angrier about I
think the shirt is the weirdest thing
for sure just because it it's almost
like they were like oh you know people
really like the shirts in splatoon that
you can get remember when you had Pizza
Hut or transformers whatever it was that
was cool and it's like no totally
different thing extremely different
right especially when Zelda is I mean
always has been a very immersive game
must yeah I'd be reminded of it's like
what I'm holding no cuz long ago before
the Hylian worth the gorons passed down
this nintendo switcher which game is
banished the king again and of course
it's [ __ ] canon yeah i mean you're
not gonna wear that no-one's gonna wear
that I know who would well the one that
actually like hit me was that hard mode
right like what at what point is that a
something that you know was I mean who
knows what hard mode exactly is you know
is it maybe more like a survival mode
type thing yes you know would make I
guess more sense but that just you know
at its at its broader like core it just
sounds like it sounds like something I
should be in the game
well here's the thing as those that as
well as the new dungeon are not
unprecedented because in Link's
Awakening when you when it came on the
game bar Color Game Boy Color they added
a dungeon to entice people like this is
a different game so I'm Game Boy Color
sunshine Game Boy you can buy it go
through this dungeon there's a few other
additional features also yes link
between worlds had the hero mode but
like you said that launched with the
game you could fly it it was harder
yelling and remote in like Ocarina of
Time 3d in the Master Quest right it was
that was released on a gamecube version
whereas when between worlds had it at
launch so this isn't just a Nintendo
question this is a question of how often
do developers release games when they're
purposely withholding things which a
game this massive and from the
development cycle it seems like it's
been through I imagine these things were
already ready to go they're just holding
it and I we're gonna see like in Super
Mario Odyssey DLC expansion pass I think
the problem I have with it again is that
or at least a worry I have it I don't
have a like immediate massive problem
with it I do agree with Rayquaza Kingdom
on Twitter that we kind of do tend to
give a Nintendo [ __ ] for things it's
always Nintendo's like that sacred
developer that's sacred of the big three
companies that we kind of seem to hold
to a higher standard even though maybe
not a higher standard we kind of think
they're there in their own bubbles so
that it seems like they're opening up to
DLC expansion basses with switch but you
know like hopefully they focus on the
right trends in the future and not just
expansion passes yeah yeah a lot of
people were hoping to see a version of
trophies and we still have no idea what
like how the online capabilities will
work with a switch we don't know a lot
about the console but we know breath
awhile will have an expansion pass for
$20 or like if splatoon 2 will have
voice chat which would be cool thanks
Nintendo or like I mean I just so many
people have pre-ordered this game right
mm-hmm I and what was like the top
pre-orders like hundred twenty bucks
right I think so how frustrated would
you be like they are if you got like the
master dish you got that and then they
are tacking on more stuff like I mean I
guess ultimately I mean that's what I
will plan to do is like just not get it
and play the game first and that's what
most people should do you mean you don't
have to get it obviously yeah yeah Leroy
Jenkins on YouTube
Leroy Jenkins on YouTube chat made a
good point
Mario Kart 8 did a season pass when I
believe on the Wii U which it was kind
of a an anomaly I think maybe maybe
because it's Zelda that it's that people
are mad yeah maybe that people would
please don't touch the Delta but I don't
know I think it was inevitable and I get
I get maybe because like I said Nintendo
has been kind of isolated from these
trends lately that they weren't used to
it like if EA had a expansion Paks was
like okay that makes sense if they
didn't have it would be weird but the
fact Nintendo has won for Zelda maybe
feels weird but I guess that's we're in
2017 now well yeah I mean yeah I mean
that is a good point that they just
they're not new to this like that the
DLC for Animal Crossing new leaf and the
Mario Kart one that Leroy Jenkins
brought up and even re-releasing Mario
Kart 8 with updated content on the
switch is something they're doing so
it's maybe people are mad because they
love Zelda so much I don't know if it's
a nostalgia thing for Nintendo that's
why people get so mad I don't I don't
know yeah it's not that angry no yeah
it's stuff I mean if they want to do
those give me switch t-shirts or stone
tablets or whatever it is then go for it
I won't touch those but I'd rather just
get the metal armor speaking of which I
showed Rob this gift this morning around
no so we're just talking about how
incredibly like simulation driven this
game is in terms of like the wildlife
animations they're showing during
there's a lot of streams in Japan
recently and Nick Diouf on Twitter was
going through making gifts out of a lot
of the gameplay apparently as you know
it's way more RPG driven in this game
you can have like different kinds of
armor you know food we need cooks he
hums and it's really - he also if you're
wearing a metal like a suit of armor in
a storm
apparently I wish I had the gift ready
add it up for Charlie did see that gift
where you get destroyed get struck by
lightning and when I say struck by
lightning I mean he gets obliterated
it's like huge suit of armor and all the
sudden you see these sparks for about
five seconds in which time period you're
supposed to like [ __ ] let me put on the
tunic or even get naked so I don't get
destroyed by lightning and then did the
ground around him just get scorched he
explodes falls over it is like a mini
nuke
it's hilarious the warnings it gives
that's it's so great it was great um yes
and then also Josh Richards on Twitter
kind of asked the same question how do
you feel the shady business the shady
business of pre-release pay DLC will
affect Nintendo games going forward I
think we're gonna see a lot more of it
on the switch generation especially if
gsella is the precursor to all of it or
I guess Mario Kart 8 but now it's Zelda
on the switch so we'll see more of it
for sure and looks like he has a big
core on sword there or just a big sword
I can't wait for this game
I really can't he's on March 30 I'm so
pumped yeah awesome so yeah those are
our thoughts on Nintendo's expansion
past DLC for people-watching thank you
for joining the chat and on Twitter we
have a good press the show coming up but
keep sending your thoughts send it to
Kali plaguey Mike McCarty Rob Handler
around Twitter and we'll hopefully get
back to you
[Music]